we've known about this for decades for
over half a century try to have a
conversation with anyone about climate
change people just - now climate change
climate change and change and the
problem seems to be getting worse and
worse and worse the truth is the more
I've learned about this issue and
everything that contributes to the
problem the more I realize how much I
don't know oh my god violet that is
paradise that has been degraded and
destroyed
we're knowingly doing this
I just want to know how far we've gone
and if there's anything we can do to
stop it
the US has been the biggest emitter of
greenhouse gases in history you're a
fossil addicted country we are doing
more investment in solar today than the
u.s. is half the people in office still
don't believe in climate change why do
you think there is such opposition about
the science
I think it's politics people are so
arrogant to think they can change
climate the environmental issues have
become the biggest reason for mass
demonstrations we want to hold them
accountable
this is the most important issue of our
time question is can we change our
course in time you need 100 gigafactory
to transition through stainable energy
that would make the united states the
whole world all energy that's all that
I've seen on my journey shows us we had
the means of stopping this devastation
politicians do what the people want them
to do once the American people are
convinced the politicians will fall in
line very quickly
if we keep pushing there's no reason why
we can't solve this problem
the world is now watching we asked you
to protect it
are we and all living things we cherish
our history
[Music]
you